في ديسمبر 2020 ، بدأ لقاح mrna في
تغيير مسار الوباء
في نفس الوقت الذي كانت فيه نفس
التكنولوجيا ربما تغير حياة باربرا بريغام
بطريقة مختلفة تمامًا ،
فقالت إنني أريدك فقط أن تعرف أن
لديك سرطان
البنكرياس. سرطان البنكرياس هو واحد من أكثر
الأشكال العدوانية
للمرض والتي تحفز الدكتور فينو بالاشاندران
في Memorial Sloan Kettering لإيجاد
علاج لها ، نحن بحاجة حقًا إلى
علاجات جديدة للمرضى ،
ترقبوا الآن العلاجات المناعية التي
تُستخدم لعلاج مرضى السرطان ، فهم
يعملون فقط في حوالي 20
من المرضى ،
حتى حوالي 80 من الوقت
، لا تكون العلاجات المناعية الحالية فعالة جدًا ،
لذا تعاون الدكتور بالاشاندران مع شركة
Biontech ، فقد
تتذكرهم كمطور لقاح mrna covet 19 ، وكان
هدفهم هو البدء في تجربة mrna
كعلاج لسرطان البنكرياس.
حاول كل
ما يمنعني من الحصول على حياة أقصر
مما كنت أرغب حقًا في
الإصابة بالسرطان ، وقد تحدى العلماء من أجل
ذ  الأذنين جزئيًا لأن الخلايا
تتغير باستمرار مما يجعل من الصعب
على الجهاز المناعي اكتشافها ولكن
هذا هو بالضبط السبب وراء عمل
مؤسسي شركة Biontech الدكتور
أوهار شاهين والدكتور أسلم توريتشي مع مرنا
لعقود لمعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكانهم التغلب على
السرطان.
إنه خاص
بهذا السرطان وليس الخلايا البشرية السليمة
في جسم المريض المحدد الذي
كان في الواقع أه
العقدين الأخيرين اللذين استثمرنا فيهما
لتحديد كيفية الحصول على أفضل الأهداف
وأفضل الطفرات وأفضل الجزيئات
للتعرف على الخلايا السرطانية و
تمييزها عن الخلايا الطبيعية ، تذكر كيف
تعمل mrna في لقاحات covid19 ، فهي
تعطي بشكل أساسي تعليمات مفصلة لجهازنا المناعي
لصنع جزء معين
من الفيروس حتى يتمكن جهاز المناعة لدينا بعد ذلك من
تعلم التعرف عليه وإنشاء
أجسام مضادة ضده ،
ويمكن بعد ذلك تصميم هذه التعليمات
و  إذا تطور الفيروس بسرعة ،
فإن الفكرة هي أن هذا يمكن أن يعمل بطريقة مماثلة
ولكن بالنسبة للسرطان هي
التقنية المثلى  علمي أن تكون قادرًا على تخصيص
لقاح سريعًا في الوقت الفعلي وهو أمر
مهم حقًا لمريض السرطان
الذي يريد رعاية أفضل تقنية
متوفرة هناك اعتقدنا أنها مرنا
دعني أشرح كيف نجح هذا لأطباء
باربرا في
البداية قاموا بإزالة الورم
وعينة من  تم نقله ما يقرب من
4000 ميل إلى المقر الرئيسي لشركة Biontech في
ألمانيا ، ما نقوم به هو ترتيب
الورم في الحمض النووي من الورم
وتحديد الطفرات عن طريق مقارنة
الحمض النووي من الورم مع الحمض النووي من
الدم لأن الدم
غير متحور  وبعد ذلك يمكنك أن ترى أو في
هذا الموضع هناك طفرة
تتضمن الخطوة التالية استخدام
خوارزمية كمبيوتر لمعرفة أي من هذه
الطفرات يجب أن تصبح أهدافًا
للقاح تلك التي
سيتعرف عليها الجهاز المناعي لباربرا ثم ينشر
الخلايا التائية لمحاربتها
استغرق الأمر ستة أسابيع فقط
حتى يتم إنشاء علاج السرطان المخصص لباربرا
، وبمجرد عودته فوق
المحيط الأطلسي ، تم ضخ جرعة اللقاح الأولى
فيها  الدم الذي كان في
15 ديسمبر 2020 تقريبًا في نفس الوقت الذي أصبحت فيه
لقاحات مرنا لفيروس كوفيد متاحة
جنبًا إلى جنب مع العلاج الكيميائي والعلاج المناعي المعياري ،
تلقت باربرا تسعة
لقاحات mrna وتقول إن
كل شيء على ما يرام حتى الآن لقد
تلقيت مناعة أخيرة في
سبتمبر والتي
كنت أيضًا  خضعت لفحص قطط في ذلك الوقت
وكان سلبياً بالنسبة لسرطان البنكرياس
والجميع يحتفلون ولكن أياً كان
الوقت المتاح لي فهو يمنحني المزيد من الوقت
للاستمتاع بأحفادي وأولادي وحياتي
أنت